fruit plate challenge
man I love blueberries hey
everybody got a really interesting video
here today given my wine background and
the overrated underrated series I
thought it was time to rank the fruit
Dustin we're gonna rank the fruit we
want an easy scaling of one to ten let's
go right to the winding and start with
the grape
Tang
smooth the skin you know when the Skin's
right like it's just firm enough it's
not soft but it's not overly hard and
then you get the gushing of the grape
very solid I'm going seven strawberries
go ahead nice little strawberry also
great balance to me with fruit it's the
firmness and the flavor ratio this
firmness flavor ratio is everything in
Fruit this strawberry was really solid
I'm gonna go with a seven Blackberry I'm
a big Blackberry guy very big on
blackberries let's see if this is good
not firm enough
I like the blackberries today it's in
season proper we're going with an 8.5
for the Blackberry pineapple I'm a fan
of pineapples just not on Pizza that
is just whack
[Music]
I like the pineapple trip we're going
with an eight for the pineapple green
melon
is this what's this candle this
cantaloupe right cool all right so relax
or is this candle open yeah and so what
the was this like sweet melon what
honeydew
you me up Dustin
[Music]
firm I'm a big honeydew
Tangy very nice I'm going with
an eight cantaloupe
by the way if you're wondering what's
super interesting about me not knowing
those two melons they're still Russian
words that when I see something in the
world my brain goes to Russian before it
goes to English and that's what caught
me up there so that's a little fun fact
for this show cantaloupe we're gonna go
with a seven it was solid but fine and
the final one blueberries let's see what
happens here
I love blueberries
money
nine blueberries win
all right that was good